miss Oprah I'm out here yes you are
girlfriend we're out here we are it is
your 20/20 vision
tour yeah what made you decide to get
out here hit the road and speak directly
to your audience well because you know I
had had some WWE members about ten of
them and their partners come to my house
in Maui and we're on our porch they were
supposed to come for lunch and then I
end up staying all day or you know if
we're on the porch drinking tequila
shots four points per shot and when they
left as is always the case when you're
doing something for somebody else
anybody watching knows this you do
something for somebody else you think
you're doing something for them it
always comes back to you the energy of
how you put that out comes back so I was
thinking about how do you get hundreds
or thousands of people on my porch could
not work even though I have a nice
wraparound porch you could not get
thousands of people on it okay how do we
actually scale this how do you take this
energy of inspiration and people feeling
triumphant in their lives how do you use
that to something that's a greater good
than just my front porch but that's how
this idea came about oh I know what I'll
try to spread that word around the
country well here you are spreading it
and it's not just about you know we're
kicking off a new year stepping on the
scale losing some weight
it is far beyond the weight loss aspect
I'm reeling over the scale I don't even
use this scale anymore I just used do I
feel well and does this fit yeah I use
do I feel well and does this fit because
I now fully have come to understand I'm
about to turn 66 and I know having been
on every diet in the world that now ww
has allowed me to stabilize and to feel
healthy inside and out with all the
numbers that matter not just your weight
but your blood pressure and your blood
Sugar's and all of that I'm healthier
than I've ever been and I do believe
that healthy is actually the new skinny
Rachel that is what I'm saying
amen Kathy
the new skinny it's all the numbers it's
just not the except the scale number I
love mr. Trump on the beach there we go
so 2020 you want it to be the year of
transformation yeah an abundance of life
experiences Oprah so what would you say
has been your biggest personal
transformation yet the biggest
transformation for me was living my life
with intention you know what I know I
live by this law that's the third law of
motion physics what you put out it's
coming back but before you even put it
out you have an intention and so to have
a clarity of intention about what you
actually want to do and why you want to
do it is the most important thing and
then to just set that vision and have
every step you make move you in the
direction of that vision it doesn't mean
that every day it's gonna happen some
days you're off track like I intended to
work out 45 minutes I only got in 37
this morning that's it's better than
zero and that's that's that's it so I
said okay at least you got some movement
in and I'll go back and I'll make up the
other eight later but I thought you just
made it actually as I was walking I
think I think this is gonna be eight
minutes I make it up so it's it's about
its daily renewal it's not one big
gigantic goal it's every day coming back
giving yourself the opportunity to get
it right because that's what every
sunrise means it's oh gosh it's another
chance to get it right allow me to have
it and intent and purpose yes it changes
everything it is it's amazing what about
something that you feel like you
personally achieved or overcome is there
something that you are especially proud
of yourself
yeah I'm especially proud of myself for
not living in the world of comparisons
you know years ago and I pulled out that
wagon of fat I was actually comparing
myself to everybody else or what I
thought you're supposed to look like or
what size you're supposed to be so I'm
now reached the point where I'm really
okay exactly where I am
and that's you know it's taken me a
lifetime practically figure that out
being okay exactly where you are earring
is a day it's so hard because we are in
the world of insta comparison you know
and so the real spiritual practice is to
like live from within and not let the
world Devine who you are but you do that
for yourself that's that's the hardest
work it truly is it is I feel like those
are gonna be some of the messages that
you are gonna be conveying in this nine
stop City tour that you're going on and
you've got celebrities joining you along
the way so how did you go about thinking
of this celebrities great for this city
friend she got Lady gaga coming what do
you hope she's well well I know what
she's gonna speak about is the truth of
her struggle to just be a whole person
you know she's I was talking to her on
the phone when I first asked her to do
it actually
I ever get intimidated but I also hate
the thing I hate the most is asking
anybody to do anything from it yeah I
just it gives me the willies to ask
anybody to do anything for me so the
hardest thing I've ever done is to ask
all of these people to come on Twitter
and coming from someone who you know a
lot of people are asking you for things
all the time you know what and I know
how I feel when they ask me that's why
it's so hard so the hardest thing was
for me to ask all these people so when I
ask God God to do it and I'm asking her
to do it on January 4th
I mean right you hardly have shaken off
your tequila yet you don't have all the
confetti out of your hair yet and when I
said I know it's a hard thing and she
said yes immediately so you know if
somebody if anybody said oh no I don't
think I could way to go okay okay I was
always the worst Booker for the Oprah
Show because the second somebody said I
don't know if I can I go okay so the
hardest thing I've ever had to do was
ask ask all these people on the tour
here we are
they said yes well you've got
former First Lady Michelle Obama yes
that was a really hard ass you got to
miss Tracee Ellis Ross yeah that was a
hard cuz Tina Fey it's in Minnesota you
have to go to Minnesota are the winner
and she told me that she was like I'm
going to Minnesota whenever it's January
but it's for Oprah's so I'm you know you
need somebody to come anybody take hey
come join me in Minnesota you're Tina
Fey's joining me in Minnesota Minnesota
oh yeah it is okay so the tour we've
been talking about this what is the
biggest challenge for you on tour well I
think the biggest challenge particularly
when you're on the road is to stay on
point
you know is to try to ease to maintain
your exercise your your your daily
routine says normally I'd get up I walk
the dogs I'm out the door that so
maintaining that healthy routine when
you're on the road cuz you know you want
to hang out with the crew you'd like to
have a couple drinks after this you know
go to bed and get your sleep and get
your rest so it's staying on track on
point right when you're on the road it's
harder now what are some of your
favorite things that you have to have
with you while you're traveling well you
know I don't have a big writer I've done
with lemon and I've been on the other
side of this microphone so I have dealt
with the people and the riders and so I
tried it you know in every hotel there's
going to be sparkling water okay and
avocados which I tried it I tried to
bring my own when I'm in the country I
bring my own avocados cuz I you grow
them cuz I grow them and also it's so
much cheaper cuz you know what they
charge in a hotel for an avocado it's
ridiculous I'm sure you got something
that zest ruffles better in your purse
never go anywhere without truffles yes
now they got hot truffles that's yeah so
I have that and that's about it and I
always have like oranges and bananas in
the room that's it I mean I'm so low
okay resolutions that time of year I
don't make resolutions anymore I have a
word so it might dinner table we all go
around the table and we say what's your
word
for this year and my word is purpose my
word for this year is purpose because
when I look back on my you know how you
can't even figure out what you did in
the year because your life so full yeah
so enough now I just go back and I look
through my phones I was doing that on
New Year's Eve looking through the phone
at all the pictures all the stuff you've
done and I did a lot of things but I
didn't do a lot of things on purpose
with intentional purpose so my thing
this year is don't do anything unless
you have an intention and a purpose
behind it purpose
[Music]